what do you think the first sign of a
vitamin A deficiency would manifest as
in your body now if you guessed Nick
delopia you are correct now what is this
Nick telopia I mean it's kind of funny
sometimes when people give you these
words that you might not understand
um then you tell them like what does
that mean they might slow it down like
nicktolopia I'm like that doesn't help
me I need to know what the heck it means
so you have to get a dictionary out and
look up the word but nicktolopia
basically is night blindness okay you
can't see in the dark too well so
whether you're driving home
um in the dark and you're having a hard
time seeing the road or it's raining out
and it's dark and you really can't see
the road or even if you're in your house
your office reading a book
and there's not good lighting okay you
may think you need glasses when in fact
you might need Vitamin A now I will say
that if you spend any amount of time
reading your phone looking at your
computer screen like I do many many
hours a day what's going to happen is
the muscles on the eye go into a spasm
okay and they stay in this little
spasm which then will affect your
ability to see then you go to the eye
doctor and you'll be fitted for
something like this
which is interesting because I when I
went there I asked the ophthalmologist I
said
um why do we need glasses
um is it a genetic problem and he goes
yeah it's a genetic problem I said that
doesn't make sense to me and then I
asked him I said looking at a computer
screen or reading a book for long
periods of time doesn't that affect the
vision he says well I can't disagree
with you yeah that probably does but
honestly these eye doctors probably are
not taught a lot of preventative type
things to prevent
um you from developing this spasm in
your eye what I would highly recommend
and I put this in a video is to get
outside every single day to try to
counter this spasm going on in the eye
by looking in the distance looking at
trees looking at things and focusing in
on purpose various things in your
environment
for at least an hour a day that would be
very therapeutic and the chances of you
needing glasses would be greatly
lessened in fact if you have glasses
you'll probably improve your eyes over
time if you did that but if you have
difficulty seeing in dim lighting or at
night while you're driving suspect a
vitamin A deficiency now there's some
interesting things about vitamin A okay
the active form of vitamin A is called
retinol okay so why did they come up
this name Retinol for vitamin A could it
be that it has something to do with the
retina which is the back part of the eye
it's an extension of your brain that
allows you to see so vitamin A retinol
the active form not beta-carotene which
is the precursor that has to convert
into retinol retinol is needed to help
you create this little protein in your
eye that converts light
two electrical signals and that's called
visual purple or rhodopsin so vitamin A
is needed to form this pigment for these
little things in your eyes that are
called rods okay and these little rods
help you see in the peripheral area of
your vision as well as low illuminated
areas right now I want to touch on this
precursor beta-carotene
um that converts into retinol it amazes
me that they actually I think they
change the definition I don't know how
long ago that beta-carotene the
precursor is vitamin A well it's not the
active form of vitamin A it's the
precursor and it has to be converted
into retinol let's just kind of compare
um the amount of retinol that's in three
ounces of beef liver because beef liver
is very very high in retinol okay three
ounces how much beta-carotene in carrots
would you need
to have the same retinol okay as in
three ounces of beef liver you would
need 40 pounds of raw carrots
that would be very difficult to consume
I mean I can see like 20 pounds but 40
pounds of carrots it's not going to
happen all right how much kale would you
need to equal the amount of retinol and
just three ounces of beef liver well you
need
454 cups of raw kale to equal the
retinol and only three ounces of beef
liver incredible it's probably not going
to happen so if you're doing
three or four or five cups of kale in
your salad whatever and you think you're
getting enough true vitamin A chances
are you're not what type of foods are
high in vitamin A of course grass-fed
beef liver okay egg yolks
cod liver oil now fish oil has the
omega-3 fatty acids but not the vitamin
A like cod liver cod liver oil has
omega-3 fatty acids as well as vitamin d
and vitamin A raw cheese
has a good amount of vitamin A raw cream
and raw butter has a good amount of
retinol but pasteurization destroys
vitamin A so if you're getting
pasteurized milk or pasteurized cheese
which is the majority of cheese or
pasteurized butter or even if you're
eating a lot of overly cooked carrots or
cooked vegetables that has the precursor
you're not going to get a lot of vitamin
A now if you're doing cheese try to get
raw milk cheese if you can get sheep
cheese you'll get a lot more vitamin A
in fact there's another animal milk that
you can get to get a good amount of
vitamin A and that is actually rat milk
so if you run out of sheep cheese milk
you always have a plan B so vitamin A is
needed to prevent night blindness okay
to be able to see in the dark somewhat
it's also needed to prevent dry eyes
it's also needed to help the eye
compensate so this is probably why if
someone's very very deficient about M A
they're going to have a hard time
focusing in on different things because
another symptom of vitamin A deficiency
is dry eyes but also dry skin vitamin A
is also necessary for any type of skin
differentiation so if you don't have
enough vitamin A your skin might not
turn into a nice soft skin it might be
rough
scaly dry skin it's also needed to help
the eye compensate for distances as well
so some of the accommodation reflex is
dependent on a certain amount of vitamin
A vitamin A is desperately needed to
prevent infections because it's very
important for your immune system and I'm
not just talking about the external scan
I'm talking about also problems with the
internal skin like the mucous membranes
of your sinuses like the internal skin
of the esophagus of the stomach of the
intestines can all be affected by a
vitamin A deficiency and as a child is
developing early on that child needs a
good amount of vitamin A so this relates
to why certain people are deficient
right a woman who's pregnant right is
more susceptible to having a vitamin A
deficiency because of the demand for
vitamin A it goes up also if she's
breastfeeding she needs more vitamin A
this is probably why uh your grandmother
or your parents recommended a spoonful
of cod liver oil on a regular basis that
delicious cod liver oil so other reasons
why people are deficient is having this
false idea that beta-carotene is retinol
it's not beta-carotene has to be
converted into retinol to be active
and that leads to another reason why a
person might be deficient in vitamin A
well there's something called
polymorphism that is the genetic
mutation that can affect certain things
in your body but apparently the gene
that converts beta-carotene into retinol
could be a polymorphic Gene it could be
mutated in fact there's a study I read
that shows that it's it's pretty common
to have a problem with that Gene that
converts beta-carotene into retinol so
that could be another reason why someone
is deficient in retinol because they
might be consuming a lot of
beta-carotene it's not converting or
they might be consuming in the active
form of vitamin A yet they have this
genetic weakness
and by the way if that's the problem I
would recommend not just increasing the
amount of retinol Foods okay I would
also add bile salts and maybe another
type of bile salt called tatka to
increase more absorption and of course
that's a perfect segue to another reason
why people are deficient vitamin A they
don't have enough bile they have bile
problems let's say they have gallstones
or they had gallstones or they have
their gallbladder removed or they have a
sludge in the gallbladder or they have a
fatty liver or some other problem with
the liver that makes bile there's a lot
of reasons why you might not have enough
bile it also could be you took an
antibiotic the microbes in your gut
actually make a certain type of bile as
well so that could be another reason
let's say for example you are in a
low-fat diet
of course if you're on a low-fat diet
you're not going to be eating the foods
high in retinol let's say you're in a
medication called Statin that blocks
your ability to turn cholesterol into
bile you end up with the bile deficiency
so taking statins can actually give you
a vitamin A deficiency as well and the
last point on why you might be deficient
is just some knowledge on vitamin A gets
destroyed with heat so if milk is
pasteurized if someone consumes milk and
it's not raw just pasteurized they're
not going to get a vitamin A or let's
say they're consuming a lot of carrots
or kale that's overly cooked okay well
that just destroys the precursor so it's
not going to turn into retinol or again
you're not consuming raw cheese you're
just doing the regular pasteurized
cheese another problem all right so now
you definitely know more about vitamin A
okay I think the next best video for you
to watch would be the one on cod liver
oil so check that out I put it up right
here